we're talking uh energy prices with the
energy minister michael fallon uh
because the the energy company sse uh
has announced it's putting up gas and
electricity prices and the average here
is an eye-popping minister uh 8.2
percent and not much notice in this 15th
of november this comes into force
no that's it's disappointing news this
morning and it's for the company to
justify a big increase of that kind but
we're already taking action to place the
most vulnerable customers on the lowest
tariffs and i would encourage anybody uh
to watching this to look at their their
gas bill and to ensure that they are on
the best tariffs to see whether they at
the end of their term they can switch to
something cheaper yeah but they're
more appealing to people is what ed
miliband said a couple of weeks ago he's
gonna if he gets into par he's gonna
freeze all this well he's already
admitted that that's unworkable because
part of the price of gas is the
international wholesale price of gas and
if you had a freeze that would simply go
up before the freeze and go up
afterwards so that's simply a gimmick
the best answer here is to simplify the
tariff structure which we're doing to
get the most vulnerable people onto the
cheapest tariffs and to encourage more
people to shop do you know what one of
the things they're doing is they're
pointing the finger at you they're
saying one of the reasons they are
having to put their prices up is your
obsession with green levees
no there's a small amount added to each
bill to help protect the most vulnerable
to help keep their warms this their
homes warm this winter and that's
extremely important but the bulk of this
is for the energy companies and it's for
them to just give you about okay okay
how much how much is actually added to
our build as a result of government
policies well to for energy efficiency
and to help keep homes warm for the most
vulnerable there's only four or five
percent of your bill goes on that it's a
very small uh uh piece on top of it
four four five percent okay well people
will be able to judge on that isn't the
truth at the end of the day um you're a
wee bit panicked about all of this
because it's making ed miliband look
very very good
no it's a gimmick he's already admitted
it can't work the best answer to this is
more competition and to make it easier
for people to switch from tariff to
tariff and to get the most vulnerable
people on the lowest tariff possible and
that's what we're doing now you don't
have to wait two or three years for some
gimmick that labor can't actually
deliver minister what would you say to
uh scottish and southern electricity
because you you know what they're
listening in they're listening in on
this we've got tony killian he's the
director of customer services at sse and
you know when i know they will not have
done this in isolation because all their
mates and all the other companies will
follow suit on this what would you say
to sse well i'd say i'm disappointed and
i said it's for them now to justify an
increase of this kind way ahead of
inflation to justify it to their
customers and it's for them to try and
keep their customers okay we're making
it easier for people to switch and
people should now consider whether they
can move to a cheaper tariff
but then they'll all put them up tony
keeling justify it to me justify it to
the minister there how much has he and
his government to blame for what you're
having to do okay the key thing i think
the key thing i'd say is that we really
regret the fact that having to put our
prices up we've tried to hold off as
long as we can do we try to keep the
increase as small as we can do but the
fact is that there are three main
reasons why prices are having to go up
which are
the energy that we buy in a global
market is increasing it's four percent
higher this winter than last winter
the cost of getting energy to our homes
has gone up 10 in the last 12 months and
then the government schemes there are
about 10 of everyone's bill is
effectively extra tax on top of the va
just up there just up there minister you
just said to me it was uh four percent
he's saying 10 percent
oh come on let's get this turned up
somebody
four or five percent um to help energy
efficiency and invest in the future and
then another amount to help protect the
most vulnerable which i think everybody
would like to see so what it is ten
percent
it is
that's not what you said to me you said
there was only four percent involved in
all of this so he has got a point you
asked me first about energy efficiency i
asked you what your contribution was to
that bill and you said four percent he's
telling me it's ten percent well let me
just correct you the uh the there is
amount that goes on energy efficiency
and there's another amount it's ten
percent it's ten percent we're at ten
percent of our bill is because of
government policy yes or no just under
10 percent whoa
right
there and is that and is that really
necessary tony keeling in your view
i think the the schemes themselves good
schemes we think it should be paid for
through general taxation we think it
should be paid for in that way so it's
targeted people that can afford to pay
it at the moment it's a blanket charge
to everybody and some people can't
afford that um and that those schemes
are going up 13 in the last 12 months
now tony keeling um the minister is
saying he's encouraging people to shop
around people should shop around if they
don't like the fact that you're hyping
things by 8.2
there are options uh isn't the truth
that there aren't really options because
the other companies are going to follow
suit with you guys you're all going to
be very much of a muchness i think the
market's very competitive there's over
20 supply companies um there's a whole
range of products that people can buy um
and people do switch around and they do
get a good deal i think you've got to
look at the price you pay you've got to
look at the service that you get you've
got to look at the advice you get from
the company as well so if you were if
you were a customer of scottish and
southern and come november your bill's
going to go up by 8.2 percent
would you blame them
for for switching to another company
would you switch to another company i
think it's really important people
understand why the prices are going up
and many companies would you switch
would you switch would you stick with
you guys would you say where value for
money
i personally would but i would look at
doing a lot of things actually i'd look
at how i'm managing my account you can
save 92 pounds a year by paying by
direct debit and getting your bills
online you can save hundreds of pounds
through energy efficiency measures that
you can do and one of the things i'd
like to say today is that there are a
lot of people that are going to be
generally worried about how they're
going to pay for their bills this winter
there are a lot of things that we can do
and if customers give us a call on 8000
727-222
there's a lot we could actually do to
help customers in that situation we're
going to we're going to charge you a lot
more money but you know what we'll make
it easier we'll take it from you bit by
bit you know that will be a big benefit
i think to people that will be a lot of
comfort and to them what would you say
to the minister to help you to do your
job is there anything more that he can
he could do to help you
i think the motivation behind all the
schemes that are on the bill are good i
think it should be moved off of the bill
that'll save people over 110 pounds a
year off their bill straight away and do
it through general taxation and then
target the people that can afford it and
then actually look after and support the
people that are going to be struggling
there are a lot i would stress though
there's a lot that customers can do if
they get in touch with us and for
example there's a one-home discount that
can save 135 pounds a year no
they'd just prefer if you didn't put it
up in the first place that's the best
thing you could do for them uh but but
minister tony king thank you very much
indeed tony killian is the director of
customer services and there he was
trying to be very serviceable to his
customers there with with that advice
let us know what you think of his advice
this morning minister final word to you
well they though you heard it it it it
should be easier to to switch people
should look at the tariffs that they're
on not enough people switch at the
moment only uh only i think uh 17 or 18
percent of people switch each year so we
encourage more people to switch we're
making the tariffs simpler and we're
putting the most vulnerable people on
the lowest tariffs but the real answer
here is more competition and i'd like to
see more competition in this market